[Musique]
bonjour à tous lundi de décembre
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 60,18 voici
les titres de ce journal une centaine de
bénévoles pour replanter 3000 arbres
dans la forêt de sainte apolline à
plaisir cette opération de reboisement
s'est déroulée samedi initiative du
conseil départemental des yvelines avec
la collaboration de l'entreprise
referais cette action retour sur le
déplacement de christophe castaner aux
mureaux le ministre de l'intérieur est
venu présenter sa feuille de route
contre l'islamisme et le repli
communautaire
une expérimentation est menée dans la
ville depuis février 2018
et puis comme tous les lundis ce qu'il
faut retenir du week-end sportif
yvelinois avec notamment la défaite de
l'union rugby centre 78 dans le
championnat honneur et nous parlerons
tout à l'heure aussi de l'arrivée des
réfugiés tibétains demain à villepreux
avec une association qui oeuvre en leur
faveur
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres on
va revenir sur ce rendez-vous qui est
chaque 1er décembre tous les ans c'est
la journée mondiale de lutte contre le
sida il ya un moment de mobilisation de
sensibilisation autour du sida si on
prend le cas de l'île de france chaque
année environ 2500 nouveaux cas sont
détectés germandrée bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le directeur d'achève prévention
alors là elle a beaucoup de vocations
cette association mais elle sensibilise
est le fait également des actions
d'informations notamment sur le sida
juste déjà pour reposer le contexte où
en est-on concrètement aujourd'hui alors
il ya ce chiffre dont on parlait en off
tout à l'heure - 7 % de cas de
contamination ça c'est la nouveauté
c'est alors c'est la nouveauté
effectivement on a donc ces nouveaux
chiffres qui ont été données par santé
publique france et qui montrent
qu'effectivement il y a donc des
nouvelles synergies qui secret sur le
territoire notamment on a
paris sans sida mais aussi ile de france
sans sida qui donc gère une nouvelle
dynamique pour lutter contre le virus du
sida et puis ce chiffre est aussi dû au
fait que aujourd'hui une personne qui
est diagnostiqué et traité ne contamine
plus par le vih et ça c'est un petit peu
donc la révolution c'est donc les
traitements qui permettent effectivement
aussi cette baisse liée donc au
dépistage qui est fait sur le territoire
c'est une idée reçue qu'on entend
constamment meurt-on du sida encore
aujourd'hui il meurt encore aujourd'hui
du sida si on n'est pas donc traité et
donc c'est important de le rappeler
si on n'a pas accès aux médicaments si
on n'est pas traitée si on n'est pas
donc diagnostic et on ne peut pas avoir
accès aux médicaments et donc on meurt
encore du sida
aujourd'hui une personne qui est
diagnostiquée traité va gagner en
durabilité en durée de vie parce qu'elle
aura accède donc aux traitements et
votre association a notamment la
vocation déconstruire ses idées reçues
on aura l'occasion d'en parler juste
après si on parle du cas de la france et
ce qu'elle contribue encore aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'elle a une place de leader
dans ce fonds mondial de lutte contre le
sida il ya une action qui remonte à
quelques mois la boucle du le ruban
rouge qui sensibilise est justement à ce
désengagement de la france
or justement donc il ya eu la boucle du
ruban rouge qui avait vu une pour
vocation de mobiliser 38 villes contre
le don que le sida et on s'est bien
rendu compte que le fait d'avoir un
levier notamment de la région
ile-de-france sur emmanuel macron a
permis justement que celui ci donc
prennent les choses à bras le corps et
que le fonds mondial soit reconstituée
pour justement permettre et on l'espère
une éradication du virus pour 2030 en
tout cas c'est ce que souhaite donc les
professionnels mais on ne rappellera
jamais assez
c'est important de sensibiliser donc
plus largement les gens là population au
dépistage
le fonds mondial c'est important mais
les actions concrètes sur le terrain
salle est dix fois plus des actions qui
sont mises en place notamment par votre
association et qui combat on le disait
de nombreuses idées reçues on entend
voilà avec les le sida ne touche que les
homosexuels les séropositifs sont
contagieux les moustiques transmettre le
sida voilà c'était 2
idée reçue qu'on peut entendre sur le
terrain ça c'est important de
déconstruire justement ses idées alors
c'est important de déconstruire et
d'ailleurs les moins 7% sont plam sont
vraiment plus particulièrement sur les
jeunes gays moins de 25 ans donc non
issus donc de l'immigration donc pour le
coup montre bien qu'il ya voilà une
vraie volonté de pouvoir aller sur le
grand public et notamment donc aussi les
publics migrants pour avoir plus de
prévention puisque on sent que sur ces
publics là les plus de 45 ans et les
migrants c'est pas encore ça qui est ça
et pour le coup il convient de
déconstruire donc ses idées reçues on ne
contamine plus si on est donc sous
traitement ça c'est quand même la
nouvelle de l'année et pour le coup les
problématiques de sérophobie font que
les gens se sentent encore est ce qu on
imagine une action aussi auprès des
jeunes ya un étudiant sur deux qui
n'utilisent pas de préservatif
aujourd'hui oui ça nous désespère ont
fait treize mille dépistages en ile de
france achères prévention réalise 13000
dépistage du vih notamment en université
et on sent bien qu'il n'y a pas de de
prévention qui est fait largement et on
sent bien que les jeunes se sentent plus
concernés pour eux aujourd'hui c'est une
maladie de vieux donc ils estiment
qu'ils sont plus du tout
et pourtant malheureusement 1 63% des
gens qui achètent prévention va
diagnostiquer donc c'est colossal sont
effectivement contaminés par le virus du
sida
et pourtant ils sont hétérosexuels et
moins de 25 ans et vous allez à la
rencontre des jeunes notamment dans les
yvelines alors l'association est né à
trappes en 2004 mais elle s'est étendue
à tout le territoire
aujourd'hui tout le territoire non mais
en tous les cas beaucoup de régions ça
me vaut deux elle est un peu partout
mais pour le coup on sent bien que
l'état donc se prend au jeu de dire que
voilà il faut innover qu'il faut aller
vers les gens ce n'était pas le cas il
ya encore quelques années on a été
pionnier là dedans l'année prochaine on
va aller encore plus loin puisque on va
aller à seize mille dépistages en ile de
france
et puis la région de ile de france est
avec nous et à nos côtés notamment et le
laboratoire gilead pour pouvoir sortir
une intelligence artificielle en espère
pouvoir la montrer
l'année prochaine en plateau ce qui
permettra notamment de pouvoir discuter
avec les gens de pouvoir aussi leur
proposer des autotests gratuit
directement livrés chez eux mais ça sera
vraiment une révolution la prévention
autour du dépistage vous en parler quand
faut-il faire un dépistage
juste avant j'ai envie de dire au moins
une fois par an si ce n'est aussi une
fois tous les trois mois si on a donc
des rapports à risque
c'est important effectivement de pouvoir
se dépister rapidement aujourd'hui on
peut se dépister dans les centres de
dépistage anonyme et gratuit donc les
cegid mais le centre de dépistage
anonyme
on peut aussi aller se dépister
directement aux labos dante dans les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
on peut aussi aller se dépister dans les
pharmacies il ya une possibilité
d'acheter dans ce qu'on appelle les
autotests on peut aussi en donner
gratuitement à chaque prévention il ya
différentes possibilités de se faire
dépister
l'idée c'est vraiment d'y penser de ce
pouvoir se dire qu'il faut aller au
dépistage le plus rapidement possible et
d'ailleurs ces lieux de dépistage on
peut les retrouver dans une application
qui a été développé par hachette
prévention s'est trouvé un préservatif
on peut trouver un préservatif et grâce
à cette application mais aussi les lieux
de dépistage chez nous c'est
l'application tubes pour trouver des
préservatifs et des lieux de dépistage
partout en france qu'ils soient fixes ou
mobiles
ça vous donne la possibilité donc
d'avoir à la fois des capotes et à la
fois du dépistage quelle que soit
l'heure on va vous donner donc les
informations
ils vont bien et puis tu peux
aujourd'hui c'est un véritable succès
c'est devenu la l'application mobile
numéro un en santé sexuelle en france lé
marrainée par marina carrère d'encausse
du journal de la santé de france 5
et pour le coup quatre cent vingt mille
personnes l'utilisent quotidiennement
c'est colossal on ne s'attendait pas
quand on a créé à chaque prévention à
autant de choses effectivement qui se
déploie et puis tu quand on l'a imaginé
où jamais on s'était dit à cinq ans que
ça veut rencontrerait un tel un tel
succès un dernier mot ce genre d'actions
auprès notamment du public jeune ya
aussi le virus war qui a été un jeu je
crois c était un un pardon un jeu en
réalité virtuelle ouais c'est un game
change en réalité de proposer ce genre
d'action oui parce qu'aujourd'hui les
jeunes ont besoin d'avoir des choses
interactive ludique et puis ça modifie
les comportements puisque c'est un game
'changer alors on l'a développée avec
des fusils laser dans un environnement
de 600 mètres carrés de zones de jeu et
puis voyant que ça marchait bien on la
crée en réalité virtuelle c'est
téléchargeable c'est gratuit vous pouvez
avoir donc directement virus soir sur
google pleyel et l'app store merci
jérôme andré directeur d'hachette
prévention on aura l'occasion de
reparler de cette association parce que
vous allez bientôt fêter vos 15 ans
mercy
[Musique]
au lendemain du séminaire des préfets
sur la lutte contre le repli
communautaire le ministre de l'intérieur
était en visite sur cette thématique
christophe castaner se déplaçait
vendredi en compagnie du secrétaire
d'état laurent nunez aux mureaux la
ville fait partie des quinze communes
expérimental d'un projet pour la
prévention de la délinquance et de la
radicalisation mathilde et demi visite
de la mairie des mureaux rencontre des
policiers au commissariat échanges avec
des associations intercultures east of
les scanners ministre de l'intérieur
présenté aux acteurs de la ville les
perspectives de la lutte contre
l'islamisme et le repli communautaire
dans le département on commence à peine
au niveau des liens c'est vrai qu'on a
déstabilisé un petit peu certains droits
des patients parce que je n'étais pas
habitué à voir des patrouilles à pied
sur secteur
nous avons vu que cette politique d'
entrave au développement de l'islamisme
a pu porter ses fruits aux mureaux nous
l'avons constaté
et donc c'est cette méthode que nous
voulons renforcer ici aux mureaux mais
que nous voulons appliquer sur
l'ensemble du territoire national ne
faut pas croire que le risque de
développement de l'islamisme serait
cantonnée à quelques quartiers y compris
des quartiers qui n'ont plus rien à voir
avec l'image populaire que l'on ne peut
avoir comme les mureaux ici dont on a vu
que les mureaux de 2019 n'ont plus rien
à voir avec les mureaux de 2000 et donc
il est essentiel que nous nous
inspirions des bonnes pratiques de ce
travail mutualisé de tous les services
pour le ministre il faut faire de la
lutte communautariste et islamistes une
priorité 1900 emplois de policiers et
gendarmes seront dédiées sur le sujet et
les lieux culturels sportifs et
associatifs qui se radicalise seront
surveillés et fermé
le ministre a rappelé que l'islam a
toute sa place en france contrairement à
l'islamisme sachez que les musulmans
sont les premiers confrontés à ces
problématiques
sauf que nous visitons et dans le cadre
des échanges nous avons précisé les noms
smoothies dans le problème dans sa
solution parce qu'il faut le visiter
dans sa solution il faut pas dire que ça
ne va pas te dire comment en comment
répond à un certain nombre de problèmes
et des deux problématiques à travers une
vision globale
une vision partagée avec un cahier des
charges exigeant une politique globale
d'accompagnement c'est ce que souhaite
christophe castaner pour les villes
sensibles les quartiers prioritaires
je pense que c'est bien que dans l'unité
républicaine nous prônions ce sujet à
bras le corps parce que il est en train
de fracturer une partie de notre pays et
tout cela n'est pas très bon signe que
nous adressons à nos concitoyens une
expérimentation qui devrait donc
s'étendre dans les années à venir sur
tout le territoire
il est occupé actuellement par plus de
700 migrants un camp situé sur un
terrain vague à achères doit être
démantelé à partir de demain par la
préfecture des yvelines ces réfugiés
tibétains vont être accueillis proviseur
provisoirement et dans plusieurs villes
du département dont une centaine à
villepreux au complexe sportif alain
mimoun
on parle de cette actualité avec une
association deux invités en plateau die
edayé dac diakité pardon je vais y
arriver d'aller diakité bonsoir
président de l'association amal il est
mou nous également habiba tilly avec
nous un plateau vous êtes porte parole
de cette association qui est basée à à
plaisir et qui rayonne dans tout le
département
elle est notamment engagée dans la cause
des réfugiés tibétains mais pas qu on
aura l'occasion d'en parler je le disais
ces réfugiés tibétains étaient installés
depuis août à achères ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'un campement de
migrants et démantelé sur place vous
êtes déjà rendu là bas
oui on s'est déjà rendu là bas
dernière depuis le 3 décembre de l'année
dernière du coup 2018 on agissait sur le
camp a mais était sur le côté de
conflans l'accord conflans sainte
honorine et du coup ce camp là il a été
démantelé
hélas cette année s'est reformé mais sur
la ville d'achères depuis août qu'est ce
que vous faisiez sur place quels types
de démission
c'était des distributions de repas de
couverture de duvet de tentes pour les
pour les personnes ce qu'ils étaient
vraiment logique on va dire nausée
devant deux voies une déchetterie donc
ces tests et des conditions très
difficiles pour l'humain donc voilà on a
apporté un peu de réconfort moral aussi
qui est très important parce que ces
personnes dont ils ont vécu des choses
très faciles chez eux
lorsqu'on se rappelle le contexte ils
ont fui le tibet une région autonome de
la chine où voilà le contexte très tendu
sur place avec le pouvoir central ils
sont en quête de liberté on peut le dire
directement ils sont ils sont un cadre
de liberté et c'est ce qui les amène
chez nous voilà parce que laisser les
valeurs de la france la liberté
donc ils se retrouvent chez nous il faut
qu'on leur montre que chez nous ils sont
libres et du coup dans quelles
conditions ils vivaient sur place
c'était des conditions assez précaire
très précaire mais après ils ont su
s'organiser aussi entre eux donc voilà
il ya des associations qui sont venus
auprès de aussi pour leur prêter main
forte mais c'est assez précaire il ya le
froid et sans rien pour se réchauffer
sans rien pour se couvrir
donc c'est assez compliqué en tout cas
les conditions qui sont sur place donc
donc c'est devenu une urgence d'agir de
démanteler ce camp est trouvé en tout
cas dans une urgence une solution de
relogement pour le moment surtout là
avec la période hivernale qui va arriver
donc là il faut c'est bien en tout cas
il fallait fallait agir il faut agir
tout ces tribus alors la prison il ya eu
beaucoup de choses qui ont été faites
pour en arriver à ce démantèlement et
plusieurs mois qu'il est demandé ça fait
plusieurs mois que c'est demandé
par la ligue des des droits de l'homme
de conflans notamment qui fait un très
gros travail avec martin et c'est donc
ces parties jusqu'en cour de cassation
conseil d'état a eu des jugements les
tours donc rire voilà là bas c'est
tomber la nouvelle est tombée
on est très content et après nous nous
n'a vraiment âgées au sein de
l'association pour mettre ça un petit
peu on va dire en lumière au grand
public sur les réseaux sociaux
et après bon c'est entouré tout de suite
de nos partenaires notamment les jeunes
du quartier du val hibou à plaisir
qu'ils se sont vraiment mobilisés engagé
notamment dans l'est dans les récoltes
devant les magasins sur le terrain puis
après aussi nous on voulait vraiment
mettre en avant les jeunes les quartiers
populaires qui se sont tous mobilisés
suite à notre appel sur les réseaux
sociaux
vous avez la ville de chanteloup
notamment en la personne de sonia qui
est une personne très engagé aussi sur
le terrain et vous espérez encore
continuer à vous mobiliser à aider en
tout cas sur place puisque pour le
moment en tout cas la prise en charge
sera assurée par la préfecture des
yvelines en collaboration avec une
association qui s'appelle acr vous
espérez aussi apporter votre pierre à
l'édifice bien sûr on est une
association locale
il est tout à fait légitime que ce soit
nous en tout cas qui faisons partie en
tout cas de de la prise en charge de ces
personnes là et l'objectif maintenant ça
va être de se battre pour qui elle ça
c'est une solution d'urgence de de
trouver peut-être des relogements plus
pérenne qui voit là sont plus stables
c'est une station priorité le premier
objectif pour nous c'était le relogement
de ces personnes là et que dans ces
conditions ça c'est atteint maintenant
la suite ça va être leur régularisation
puis après ben
leur trouver des logements et qui
s'insère dans la société
ça fait partie de vos missions ça avant
de parler des autres aussi publics qui
sont aidées d'aider ces personnes en
plus de les aider de les accompagner
dans des dans des démarches
administratives aussi par exemple
c'est important pour nous de les
accompagner parce que il suffit en fait
il suffit pas de simplement faire une
action mécanique mais le suivait morale
etc
c'est très important pour nous on sait
que ils vont bien il s'insère dans la
vie et après ils réussissent et mala
après on peut les on peut les laisser
tranquillement faire leur vie il ya un
mot pour terminer sur les missions plus
globale de votre association qui
s'adresse à ces réfugiés tibétains mais
pas que ce sont des actions humanitaires
orienté vers tous les réfugiés aussi les
sans abri sans abri personnes sdf toute
personne nécessiteuse donc voilà ça peut
être en forme de colis alimentaires en
forme de maraude
donc voilà ou lorsqu'il ya des
catastrophes naturelles aussi donc on
peut agir aussi donc à ce moment là donc
après ça on a aussi les hôtels sociaux
donc pour égayer les journées des
enfants
ben on essaie de femmes et 15 messe donc
voilà donc c'est aussi un moment qui est
important donc pour les enfants qui
n'ont pas l'habitude d'aller dans des
endroits
enfin dans des grands parcs parc astérix
et ses amis en tout cas à ce moment là
ils peuvent ils peuvent se procurer un
peu de bonheur à ce moment là quoi et on
retrouve toute l'actualité toutes les
informations sur cette association mali
les moon ou sur la page facebook qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci d'ail
et diakité et merci à guy a bâti lead
être passé sur ce plateau et concernant
l'accueil des réfugiés tibétains à
villepreux un la commune a assuré dans
un communiqué que 100% de ses activités
sportives seraient maintenus tout comme
le téléthon un pendant cette période
hébergement certaines activités seront
transférés temporairement à l'espace
michel petrucciani et d'autres
structures communales
[Musique]
une grande journée de plantation samedi
dernier la forêt de sainte apolline à
plaisir s'est agrandie et de 3000 arbres
supplémentaires initiative portée par le
conseil départemental des yvelines et
l'entreprise referais cette action plus
d'une centaine de bénévoles et près tu
es venu est venu prêter main forte sur
place retour avec mélanie poker bottes
beiges et gants ils étaient plus d'une
centaine à pied d'oeuvre ce samedi ses
bénévoles plantes être échelle pour
reboiser la forêt de sainte apolline
quand je vois toutes les actualités j'ai
envie de que ça change quelque chose de
durable aussi quelque chose qu'on peut
laisser aux générations futures
donc ça c'est ça a du sens durant ce
week-end près de 3000 arbres ont été
plantés sur une parcelle de 15 hectares
deux essence principal accompagné
d'autres armes pour favoriser leurs
pouces
on va mettre les chaînes au milieu du du
carré autour on va faire un périmètre a
que des boulots des pins sylvestres ou
des charmes qui vont avoir une fonction
de gainage d'ailleurs qui vont créer de
l'ombre au tour des chaînes et des
chaînes donc vont être contraint de
pousser un petit peu en hauteur pour
cette action les yvelines se sont
associés à reforestation une entreprise
qui intervient dans 20 pays
la plantation vise à aider la
régénération dans certains cas la
régénération naturelle ne se fait pas
tout seul cercle n'y a pas de nouvelle
génération qui arrive est donc là il
faut l'accompagner
là on est sur une première vague sur sur
l'année et demie de 3000 arbres mais on
compte bien aller bien au delà je parle
de la forêt de sainte apolline bien sûr
mais pas uniquement sur tous les espaces
départementaux la forêt de sainte
apolline est un massif de 300 hectares à
dominante fut surplombant le plateau de
versailles elle est gérée par le
département les yvelines possède 36% des
espaces forestiers sur son territoire ah
bah voilà une catastrophe écologique
dans les yvelines en février dernier le
'pipeline' ile-de-france de total seront
paix au niveau d'eau tout y est de
boissy sans avoir le préfet des yvelines
vient d'autoriser le groupe pétrolier
par arrêté à exploiter à nouveau le
'pipeline' son utilisation reste
toutefois sous basses pressions est la
préfecture demande également à total
d'effectuer de minutieux test de
détection de fissures pour rappel cet
événement avait provoqué la fuite de 900
mètres cubes d'hydrocarbures dans des
champs environnants
six associations avaient porté plainte
contre x pour faire toute la lumière sur
les responsabilités
c'est une initiative lancée il ya tout
juste deux ans à guyancourt les pieds du
rotor est une épicerie bio 100 salariés
initié par la sauce régale le principe
chaque adhérent elle donne un peu de son
temps pour la gestion des produits et
des produits sains qui viennent de
producteurs locaux en circuits courts
premier bilan avec mélanie poquet la
voix de marie hélène iapichino
rouge thurgovie les eaux claires est
adhérente depuis un an une épicerie bio
100 salariés
les pizzas ou trois rallyes en cours au
départ je suis venu pour trouver ce que
je cherchais puis au fur et à mesure
on peut être force de proposition dès
qu'on connaît un petit producteur en
parler et en fait le proposer monté par
des membres de l'asso se régale il ya
trois ans l'épicerie fonctionne depuis
deux ans à l'ouverture de l'épicerie une
vingtaine d'adhérents il participe et
aujourd'hui ils sont 65
le principe c'est que chacun donne deux
heures de son temps par mois donc au
final ça peut paraître beaucoup mais en
fait c'est comme on réfléchit c'est en
fait on au lieu d'aller ailleurs de
regarder un film qui dure deux heures
dont on vient une fois par mois
participer à un forcément l'épicerie un
lieu unique où aujourd'hui sont vendus
les produits de 30 producteurs venus de
toute la france comme les terres du
lendemain maraîcher de molière on essaye
de distribuer le maximum en local pour
pour revaloriser les producteurs locaux
et les produits locaux parce que nous du
coup on produit des légumes et des
plantes aromatiques en permaculture on
aimerait que ça puisse toucher 1 au
moins le public local quoi en premier
lieu pour les prochains mois les pidio
vous trouvez arts vise la centaine
d'adhérents prochain projet un café
participatif et comme tous les lundis
miquel et demi d'euro bonds soir sans
grégory journalistes aux sports de la
rédaction de tv 78 pour nous faire un
panorama des principaux résultats
sportifs du week-end du rugby pour
commencer miquel on va parler de
division d'honneur lui verser 60 18
n'est pas passé loin d'une victoire du
rc 78 roxy fois c'était le choc de
milieu de tableau de division honneur et
ce match a tenu toutes ses promesses
après une grosse bataille dans la
possession le stade roger couderc de
montigny le bretonneux a finalement vu
les visiteurs s'imposer dans les
derniers instants du match score final
18 à 17
rageant forcément pour les saint
quentinois n'écoute les réactions à
chaud c'est pas compliqué ils ont fait
un très beau match mais son jeu comme il
fallait à l'extérieur ils ont réussi à
prendre le score et derrière ils ont des
bons angles human qui ont bien joué
bien gérer bien gérer les temps forts
temps faibles et du coup bas à la fin ça
joue à rien mais c'est pour eux je
n'avais pas un mauvais match en effet
dès qu'on se crée les occasions pour
pour aller au bout il y avait plein de
petites erreurs dans des zones de marque
qui nous coûte cher parce que l'arrivée
on meurt à un point alors qu'on aurait
dû beaucoup plus scoré pour pour faire
moins active aux deux équipes
donc effectivement on fait une belle
prestation et on a fait passer à la
trappe d'ailleurs la dernière minute
sommet de huit points à cinq minutes de
la fin de ce fait on se fait remonter
quand même donc mais on n'a pas perdu
pied on est allé jusqu'à la fête
jusqu'au bout de la concentration de la
lucidité pour aller rechercher les
points qu'il fallait malgré cette
défaite lui verser 60 18 prend le point
de bonus défensif les saint quentinois
se retrouve 3e du championnat et 23
points et 5 victoires depuis le début de
la saison un bilan inattendue après huit
journées pour ce nouveau club issu d'une
fusion entre le sky rugby et
montigny-le-bretonneux
il était très positif avant le match un
peu moins aujourd'hui
maintenant c'est une fusion si donc un
groupe est en train de se créer donc
c'est aussi des matches comme ça qui
nous permet de renforcer ce groupe
un objectif déjà c'était sportif à la
base on se prend un petit peu au jeu
maintenant et finir dans les quatre
premiers
ça va être dur mais faut être ambitieux
prochain match pour lui rc 60,18 le
dimanche 8 décembre sur le terrain de
l'ani une équipe de bas de tableau de
division honneur du football pour
continuer ça va mieux pour trappe
troisième match sans défaite pour trappe
dans le championnat de régionale 2
jouer ce week-end contre livrés à
domicile et les trappistes ont gagné 1 à
0 devant leurs supporters cette
troisième victoire de la saison permet
au joueur dit shah mardi de reprendre
espoir dans la course à la montée
les tapis sont 9e sur 12 équipes
engagées prochain match contre
versailles pour le derby évinois le 15
décembre prochain toujours à domicile et
on termine par du basket un résultat de
nationale 3 9e journée trappe s'est
imposé 79 à 77 face à fécampois sur son
parquet de son côté le chesnay
versailles s'est imposée 74 56 à
domicile
au classement on retrouve les deux
équipes évinoise dans le top 5 le
chesnay versailles est deuxième à un
petit point de la première place ces
trois pointes à la quatrième place du
classement
la 10e journée est programmée le
week-end prochain merci michael ces
résultats et bien d'autres encore à
retrouver dans quelques minutes sur tv
votre émission le 7-8 sport on devait
vous passez ce soit un sujet bilan sur
les qui rendent au vous le retrouverez
demain dans cette édition du journal sur
tv 78 à retrouver donc mardi sur tv 78
va se quitter sur ces images la
destruction du bâtiment de l'ancien
bureau de poste de saint quentin en
yvelines situé avenue du centre à
montigny le bretonneux
le chantier a démarré il va se
poursuivre en ce chantier de démolition
jusqu'à vendredi les activités du bureau
ont été transférés pour rappel est dans
des nouveaux locaux depuis cet été au
sein du centre commercial espace saint
quentin à la place du bâtiment détruit
un futur édifice qui sera occupé par
l'opérateur orange
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi j'aurai le plaisir de
vous retrouver dès demain pour une
nouvelle édition belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]